jelly tots right yeah it's like kids how
would you say that
in a lilting english accent jelly tots
jelly tots
i love how suddenly you said it perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
hello this is steve carell and this is
snack wars uk versus usa
on lad bible we're doing snack wars uk
versus usa because i am from the usa and
i'm going to look at the uk snacks as
compared to the usa snacks determine
which one i like
no one really cares but i'm going to say
it anyway
okay
this yeah
i didn't even know it was called goober
but the the swirl the peanut butter
jelly swirl
i uh i'm a big peanut butter and jelly
fan i actually had a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich this last
before i got on the plane to come here
because i wasn't sure whether it was
going to be eating on the plane
so i had a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
yep you know
that's pretty great there's another
component you can add
not commonly done in the united states
but i like to do it is put peanut butter
jelly and uh
fluff
the um like marshmallow the marshmallow
fluff we have it
you do that's exactly right
wow
that is what i call service
um
oh and it's fresh yeah yeah yeah i
highly recommend this because you know
what
peanut butter and jelly just isn't sweet
enough
a sandwich so oh
here we go
a little bit of fluff on the top
yeah
that's a complete meal
as my mom would say
it's all protein
um this
is pronounced marmite right
i don't
when you see yeast the word yeast on a
label
it doesn't
naturally lead you to think of delicious
eating but
milk
okay
oh wow
okay i've never
rich in b vitamins
and it's vegan
so do
two great things going for it
i'm gonna stick with my pb and jack
i guess i don't have to close my eyes
before i take it off because i can't see
it
you told me you told me you told me to
close my eyes so this is
this whole thing
how long have you been doing the show
okay
oh okay here we go
this would be your traditional original
beef jerky
always always good on a road trip you
know when you don't want to stop and if
you want to gross out everybody else
who's in the car with you
because it really
it's very pungent in an enclosed space
you can probably smell it already
well that's just good
beef turkey is delicious
scratchings
mist
i love
i love the brand name
mr porky
is this a very common
brand name yeah
i've never i've never sampled any of mr
porky wares
porky's oh
are these like pork rinds
kind of yeah it's not that poor [ __ ] fat
isn't it
it's joe
that
you made it sound
that much better
no no see
you look at it and it's mr porky and
there's mr porky on the on
that's him
and he looks so excited and happy
and they're called scratchings which is
cute and then you say it's just fat
all right
oh
oh that's so gross
um
all right i don't want to get into
trouble with the porky company but this
is that's that's not for me i would i
would stick with this
oh boy it's really small
oh boy
when you want deep fried pork fat
finish it off with a dr pepper zero
jelly tots
and
toxic waste
that's that's what's so wonderful about
i literally have no
thanks
and each bag includes its own pair of
scissors
um
oh and they're individually wrapped
by it's
that's a workout
so these are like hard candy
that
oh that's horrible
wow
no no no
[Applause]
no
no there's i can't leave this one in my
mouth
thank you
sorry
to describe the time wow
wow
no that
oh
wow
that just gets worse and worse
the more you suck on it sour sour's fine
but that's ridiculous
oh those are good
up to friendly little candy
jelly tots right yeah like kids
how would you say that
in a lilting english accent jelly tots
jelly tops
i love how suddenly you said it perfect
i only have four or five hundred of them
iron brew
mountain dew
i like i like the
the rhyme there
i went through a mountain dew phase i've
never had it what does it taste like
you've never had mountain dew um
it tastes like a
yellow ray of sunshine
[Laughter]
and this is
are you going have you heard of it
before i've never had it okay so it's
the drink of scotland
okay and they love it and it's orange so
it's haggis soda exactly okay
oh i like that a lot actually yeah i
think that's delicious yeah it has a
yeah i i like it i like i like how it
lingers on the tongue i can't believe
i'm talking about it like
like i'm a wine connoisseur
talking about the varietal
characteristics
of mountain dew as a um
so it's iron brew yeah um i like this
better oh great yeah delicious cool
all right
space raiders
pickled onion
all right these are the americans right
nice
these are english
oh tj
tgi fried okay i'll have those second
party bites mac mac and cheese party
bites
it's not a party oh these are like just
yeah they're like cheese puffs yeah oh
that sounds good they're not bad yeah
corn corn cheesy yeah
yeah cheesy goodness
these aren't this isn't fried fat again
is it
okay
i'm going to say the space raiders
really yeah they have more flavor to
them those are good i like those
the pickled onion let's
who wants to kiss
well i think that was maybe a trouble
really
yeah i didn't do that intentionally
i think the uk one oh the uk one sorry
apologies
all right but for the purposes of the
edit we'll do a reaction to both
i want you to tell me to react to i want
you to say the word can you react yeah
okay ready
the uk one can you react
[Music]
[Laughter]
they'll say the u.s one okay
the u.s one can can you react
okay
that's a wrap
you know what
really what we learned here is it's just
an awful lot of good food
yeah what was your best to have
everything here the best out of ever i
you know what the biggest surprise
were
those martian crisps or whatever
[Laughter]
i will say this you know what
rema please rename the martian crisps i
i will go with the space raiders i i'm i
will buy a bag of those at the airport
but we actually have a full bag that you
can take home as well
oh my god
i got a parting gift
thank you now my my name my face is
going to be on billboards for this
product now
that was amazing
i hope you enjoyed that that was fun
break sausage roll i could tell you that
already it's a sausage roll all right
i have five minutes to live don't i
my favorite
i'm sorry it says the greg's the sausage
roll it's pretty good